so let's tie
um some of the drills together okay so
for
example if we take the early drills in
the C cultivation
set his young aspect I'm learning to
stop it from going straight over my
shoulder internalize it and bring it
down to that CR on the back in the Drone
okay in the back foot in the Drone so
he's pushing if I if I lose that
connection it'll go it'll knock me
over okay so he's
using this tactic of spinal displacement
but I'm using it for energetic
development
okay to do that my whole body itself has
to be grounded so yes he we have a
horizontal young aspect but my flesh
descending is already that okay so when
I
start he's already hided he's already
hit
grounded young do you do you understand
that okay it's not that I'm here like
that and then I try to I try to find
that
okay so
um this is why for
example um if he climbs up the arm in
another drill that we've done it doesn't
doesn't change anything he keeps
climbing it doesn't change anything
because of I had
already vectored or internalized
or did an Alchemy on my body so that
doesn't change change anything at all
okay we know
also that's why it doesn't matter
whether you're on one foot or you or you
have no
base doesn't doesn't matter the same
thing is happening okay same thing he
climbs up he's climbing up he's climbing
up it doesn't matter if I lo if I lose
the connection his or the organization
that aspect will go back to its
horizontal trajectory goes into my
shoulder and it knocks me over
okay if we look then at shman buy and we
want to do this right to do it right we
want to do
it uh
energetically we don't want to make it a
conditioning
exercise if we we interested in
conditioning then we should for example
I want more strength don't get a heavier
book in per se squat because you're
going to get stronger
right uh if you're interested in some
sort of aerobic conditioning uh don't go
faster on your showman
suboy uh do a hit workout instead that's
going to work work you out better okay
if we get away from that idea that this
is a physical conditioning
exercise then I don't start looking like
I
am you know 1970s aerobics
where they have the steps you
know you do that you just we don't want
to do that okay so
instead I'm going to
have my foot alignment I always have so
I use my middle toe
straight
or slightly in is even okay out however
is not going to be good
why your going to put my away towards my
heels and uh now I'm already off the mid
fooot it's everything goes downhill okay
but you see that a lot right you see
this a lot it's wrong okay
um in the same way that when he was
pushing all parts of my body are ground
vectoring okay so uh my hand is my elbow
is my shoulder is that's why he can't
push it over it's already going down
okay um so
likewise when I'm
here everything is going down it's the
same releasing drill I always do which
is why when I was in this stance he
still couldn't push me over it's already
being
grounded
okay when I come and I add the sword to
it or I add my hand placement to it the
sword itself is now part of that midfoot
grounding that's what I'm doing
to let my
hands uh take full advantage of The
Descent of the cut in
shanin they have to freely drop so I
don't want to hang them up
anymore this this would be
wrong but this is wrong too because my
hands can still freely drop if I release
where do they stop where they hit
they're going to hit your body
so if you look at it just in terms of
architecture the sword has to be in the
middle of my body for
Shi
okay and then my hands have to release
all the way because my shoulders will
release they'll descend my elbows will
descend and my hands and wrists will
descend and so this is where the cut
ends this is incorrect
this is incorrect there's still more to
draw okay so this is the bottom
part when I come up all I want to do is
correlate or
connect or utilize the dropping and
raising of my center of
gravity with the chi dropping and
raising
so I don't have to do this much rise and
descent to have that happen so for
example with no movement in my Center in
my center of gravity itself as I lift
the sword my center of gravity is coming
up hence you can do a lot of exercises
with no movement at all I lift the
center of gravity I descend the center
Gravity the shoulder the elbow and the
Hand stay connect connected to that
rising and falling as that weight of the
shoulder elbow and hand pass through to
the midfoot I'm lifting it from the
midfoot just like I lift UK at the end
of it of my wrist and grabbing on it
goes through the midfoot my own flesh
goes through the midfoot the sword
everything goes through the midfoot and
as it comes up the center of gravity
Rises and as it comes down down the
center of gravity drops and I'm using
all of this the chi to the center of
gravity going up and
down my legs then all I want to do is
assist slightly in that
process so as I come up there is a
slight
pressing
into the increased yangong energy from
pulling the bulk in away from the earth
so I I lift the sword up with that
ground Vector it comes up center of
gravity travels up my body and now what
I do is I connect shoulders elbows hands
soord to The
Descent
boom when I
end it's from releasing it's not from
bending my knees it's from releasing the
qua and I Dr I'll drop as the sword goes
down the center gravity goes down you'll
feel the weight I release to the
weight and my qua drops drops anywhere
from a half inch to 2 in Max that's all
you need
releasing shoulders elbows hands into
the mid
foot
releasing the qua the knees will go out
and the tissues will drop the spine will
lengthen the tissues of the glutes will
release the lower legs will
release okay let's get
that lower your chin a little the crown
of the head head is the top of the
spine not not the top of the head the
crown of the
head you you have a breathing
constriction at
the throat
Andrew okay so all this whoa do you see
the the sword
so the uh what I'm doing
here is if this was already grounded
what happened was as I pushed on the
sword his weight went back okay so
likewise wherever
I that shouldn't happen Okay so find the
find
it you got you're using tension you got
to
release the gooey in the center
let you get there there you see how
you're shaking come on out it's not
flexion
me
okay so he's going to sink just just
like the off of s you see he sinks he's
sinking everything my horizontal energy
sinking wrist sinking elbow chest his
whole body is sinking so when he trades
position the horse dance nothing changes
disconnect so you can see that I am
pushing
okay start again it's exactly the same
no in onion it's exactly the same as the
C you drill but what you what we're
missing is we're not
realizing he's sinking his body okay not
just my energy and he goes he should be
able to go there's I'm pushing that
whole time there was no movement forward
you see okay can you hand me his
sword he's there he's doing the same
thing I'm still pushing here I am I'm
pushing again disconnect for me please
and you could see okay so that's what
we're trying to get and it's inside the
Sai movement okay all right try again